Department workshop. We will now adjourn the Housing Department budget
workshop and begin our budget workshop for the Houston Public Library.
Thank you very much.
Oh,
hello. Are you ready?
Yes, ma'am. At this time, I would like to welcome Director RIA Brown Lawson
and hope to
provide the Houston Public Library budget presentation.
The floor is yours. Thank you. And hello,
everybody. Thank you for the opportunity to present
the Houston Public Library's proposed budget for fiscal
year 2023. Before I begin,
I'd like to take advantage of this opportunity to
publicly thank and acknowledge the members of the Houston Public Library
Executive Leadership Team and other
staff who are responsible for
helping the library to be one of the
best library systems in the country.
So I'd like to publicly thank and acknowledge all
those members of the executive team. It is my honor
and privilege to work with a team of professionals with such
an array of talent, innovativeness creativity, and deep commitment
to provide equitable services to the residents of our great
city. I would also like to thank and acknowledge the Houston Public
Library Foundation for their unwavering support of the
library and their support of the library's programs.
Joining me today for the presentation is the Library
Department's chief Financial officer and Assistant
Director Hope Wabakesee. With that,
I will now present our proposed FY.
And if you would come a little closer to the microphone. Absolutely.
Is that better? Yes, ma'am.
Okay. Slide two presents the library's functional organizational
chart. The chart shows the distribution of
the proposed FY 23 budget and FTEs
within the six divisions of the library.
Next slide.
Slide three outlines departmental
programming and considerations relative to major services,
statutory requirements, and the financial impact
on service delivery regarding services
and programs. The library remains committed to
the delivery of equitable quality services and resources in
multiple formats to all residents of Houston through
the department's network of 38 libraries embedded in
neighborhoods throughout the city, the mobile lab
and three history research collections
and the Central Library.
Next slide.
I'm sorry. Same slide. Also in high demand
are resources for small businesses, new entrepreneurs
and job seekers. The library's network of 38 locations
throughout the city also service critical community hubs,
which include two technic facilities, three history
research centers of Texas history,
african American history and genealogical resources,
with over 193 print volumes,
2500 archival and or history collections,
and 320 microform resources per
state law. In terms of statutory
requirements per the state law,
the Texas State Library and Archives Commission,
or Tslac, sets the standards and requirements for
the accreditation of libraries throughout the state.
State accreditation eligibility requires a per
capita of 17 dollarsfifty,
cents and at least one item of library
materials per capita. The libraries
per capita for the state FY 21
annual report was 16.90.
To fill the gap, HPL submitted
supplemental maintenance and security dollars from GST
for the last two years as part of the support for library
operations to help meet the Tslac accreditation
requirements. With the budget increase this year,
we should be poised to meet state accreditation standards during
the next reporting period.
Financial or societal impact of the City service
delivery includes 1.4
million cardholders have access to 3 million
print and digital resources. In a world where
having technological access is a basic necessity,
the library is the largest provider of free Internet
access in the region. Through their neighborhood libraries,
Houston residents have access to WiFi,
hotspots, tablets and computers.
According to the Texas State Library, for every one
dollars invested in public libraries in Texas,
the community sees a return of approximately
$5.
Anticipated growth or reduction of population served
in FY 23.8 million people utilize the library
in person or via the website.
With Houston's growth in current user demand requiring more
robust Eservices and programs, we have seen
marked increase in digital services,
which is up currently. 28% from
FY 2020 database use
increased 41% last year, especially the
use of Linda.com, where users access
instructive videos to build creativity
and business skills to achieve personal and professional goals.
This increased demand is particularly impactful to
the department's budget, as databases and electronic
resources are very much more costly than
print materials. Slide Four this
slide provides an overview of the department's revenues
from FY 21 actual to FY 23
anticipated revenues. The library is not a
revenue generating department, but it does contribute
to the General Fund through passport Services and
the central library parking garage.
The Historic Preservation Fund generates revenue for the Julia
Addison Building, which is used to support the
special maintenance that is required for this historic building.
The special revenue fund is associated with the Mayor's
Office for Adult Literacy.
Next slide.
Slide five provides revenue highlights.
We anticipate returning to pre pandemic operations
in FY 23, which will contribute to an increase
in the revenue generated from the Passport services fees.
The increase in facility rental fees is mainly
due to the Frenchies restaurant rental for Smith Library
parking. The grant transfer is a onetime
FEMA insurance allocation to reimburse Kendall
library books and materials that were lost due to
Hurricane Harvey.
Next slide the
library's expenditures for FY 23 reflect
an increase of 13.7% based
on mandatory salary and benefit increases
and an increase in the books and materials budget.
The Historic Preservation Fund expenditures do not affect
the General Fund as rental revenues cover expenditures
for improvement in historical maintenance of the Julia Odds
building. Next slide.
Slide seven outlines the FY 2023
expenditure highlights. For personnel services, there was
a 3% hope increase fringe benefit
increase minimum wage increase, an additional
29 positions for staff two
staff, two new library buildings, a leaf and Dr.
Shannon Walker and the Kendall Renovated library.
FY 23 will be the first time in several years
that we will have all HPL locations open
and fully operational, requiring an increase in staffing.
The increase in supplies and services will be used
in the libraries just mentioned. The budget
also reflects an increase in the restricted accounts.
The 1.7 million increase in books and materials
relates back to the one time FEMA insurance allocation
that covers Kindle library books and materials, an improved
increase of 1 million that would allow HPL
to meet the Texas State Library accreditation standards.
Next slide. The primary
drivers in library expenses are personnel and
materials. Personnel expenses for the
library represents 72% of our total budget,
and the nonpersonal budget is 28% of
the nonpersonal budget. Non capital books and materials represent
46%, restricted accounts,
25%. Services represent 22%,
and supplies represent 2%.
Next slide. Slide nine
shows our operating budget of 30.4
million, with restricted accounts totaling
13.6 million. The contracted
and mandated adjustments total 1.5 million.
Our proposed FY 23 budget is 50,000,000.342,
which reflects a change of 14.1%.
Next slide. The chart
on slide ten represents the library's history of
being good stewards of the allocated funds the department receives.
Next slide. This concludes my
formal presentation, and I'd like to point out that the
appendix contains the library's workplace analysis,
including staff numbers and demographic information,
departmental accomplishments for FY 22,
and restricted account details. I'm happy
to answer any questions that you may have.
Thank you, Director, for your presentation. We will now take questions
from council members who will each receive two minutes per the normal committee
rules. First in the queue is vice mayor pro TEM martha castex tate.
Director Lawson, thank you for your presentation. You know, I love the library
and all that you all stand for, and all that we do in the city
of Houston, especially around adult literacy. Super excited
about the Dr. Shannon Walker Library coming to District K
soon. Based on your stat on
page three, we should see a big return in societal
impact in District K with the new
library coming on board. But my question is,
can you talk a little bit about the revenues from the
passport services as we look at our budget and
how we can increase revenues in the city? I was intrigued at
our meeting that we have four or five passport
offices in libraries.
I'd be happy to pre pandemic. We were
providing million dollars worth of passport
services through the city, through five locations.
Five locations? Yes, and we
anticipate they're very popular. Let me just say
we're better than the post office. You can quote me on that.
And we have many people complimenting
our staff on the process, so they like
to use the library, and during our
discussion council Member you're wondering why we don't
do it in more locations and generate more money.
And our conversation accounted with.
Well, if we do more locations, maybe the library can keep half
and the city can get half. So a million apiece.
We'll do ten locations.
Okay.
Would you need additional staff? If we put five more passport
offices in five libraries, will we need additional staff,
or would staff be able to cover that, will we be able to see
a bigger gain, or would we need to actually hire additional
staff for that running of five additional passport offices?
I think we would definitely need more staff.
We did five more locations. We'd need at
least five more staff members, but they would pay for themselves with a
million dollar five passport offices.
We've generated a million dollars through
the revenues we have.
Okay. And that money went back to the general fund and not to the
library. Every cent went back to the general
fund. Okay. Council Member Robinson.
Thank you. Chair and Director, thank you so much for all you
do with such limited number of staff. It's really,
truly remarkable. So I want to thank your team personally for that. And of course,
you and I are also working on what we hope will be a map archive
for the Julietison Library downtown. So referring
to that same chart of revenues that the Vice Mayor Pro
TEM referred to on page four, that category of special
revenue fund, while we're talking about it and thinking in particular
about the Julia Idison I know it's come to my attention that that is
the number one venue in what,
the city for weddings. Help me with this director. We are
rated on a national scale of being the top ten
places for holding weddings. Yes.
Okay, so that's top ten in the United States of America.
Absolutely. Okay, so while we're talking about passports,
let's talk about people getting married at libraries. I love that.
Let's do that. Just for the record, I am a single
man, but I know that's beside the point. We'll hold a spot.
How much money you got? Says the vice member.
Yeah. Another aside, but it does
raise the question about potential
revenue sources for our beautiful facilities. Because whether
it's the new library that's going into District K, whether it's the incredible
facility that's going into District F on the West Side,
our flagship libraries that are
downtown and the ones that we know are most used whether
those funds go back into the general revenue fund or how else
we categorize those revenues, I'd be really interested,
because it strikes me that what we do, as Vice Mayor
Pro TEM pointed out, for societal impacts,
that is really something that you'd think
could fuel some staffing and fuel some activities throughout
the city. If you cared to comment, we'd love to hear from you.
Sure. And we're really excited about all our
historical buildings, and with the right
amount of staff and promotion, we assure that
we could generate even more activity around
them. But you're
only able to do that based on your capacity to
do it. And so you would need, like, any other
venue staffing around that.
That would be the answer. Capacity is everything,
right? And again, with the great resignation chair, that's going to be a challenge
for this department. Like every other one we've heard from today, but thank you,
director. You're welcome. Council member came in. Thank you,
Dr. Lawson. First off, we love our libraries.
Thank you to the entire team. Can you
say it one more time? When it came to Internet,
as a provider of Internet accessibility, did you say
that our libraries are the largest provider in
the region? In the region, yes.
And given the digital
divide that we saw during the
Pandemic, especially with students and youth that did not
have access to Internet, I'm assuming that those programs are continuing
beyond the Pandemic. Oh, yes. What we did during the Pandemic
was to install high powered
antennas on several of our locations so that
those families that did not have Internet
access could, at least from our parking lots with libraries
closed, have that kind of access.
And some of them were strong enough to bleeding to the homes that
were nearby. But broadband
is a national issue, as we all
know, and having access to
the Internet is now like having electricity
in your home. It's a necessity because if
you don't have it, you are cut off from a lot of information that's
needed. We see people using libraries
to apply for jobs to hold. They rent
out spaces so that they can hold job interviews, because most
job interviews now are online.
We see number
of citizens borrowing hotspots so that they can
take that hotspot into their home and have Internet
access. All that we're doing,
and we're doing a lot, it's a drop in the bucket for the whole
conversation around broadband and its necessity.
Maybe place back in queue. Go ahead.
Thank you, and I appreciate that. And all the efforts
to confirm all of the libraries are now
back up and running that were prior to the Pandemic. So they're open for
all. And I'm asking because we're coming up on Summer, where our
libraries again play that really important role out of
school to keep children sharp
during the summer. They engage in summer
reading. And yes, our libraries will be open for
those activities to keep their minds
active through having fun.
Through reading and having fun and library
programs during the summer because there
is national research that shows
that kids that are not engaged during the summer do lose as
much as a grade level and it provides a safe place for them
to be sometimes. The last two
other questions I had really quickly. One, do all of our libraries
provide printing and scanning services currently for
the public? Scanning, like scanning digital
paper copies that they may need to be scanned, but also printing
services? I'm not sure if all
of them do, a number of them do.
I can get that answer to you. I would just be interested in the cost
breakdown of what that is. I know I've been looking in the district if there's
something that needs to be supplemented out of district service funds for printing,
oftentimes, again,
for those that may not be able to afford it. Right. Those people that are
trying to apply for a job and may need just those few extra dollars,
those types of needs. I'm just trying to explore that.
Printing is everywhere. Scanning. That's what
I'd have to check on. Okay, I would appreciate that. And lastly,
due to the financial constraints that the city continues to
face throughout every single department, what are the
needs that you foresee for the most immediate and long term
future that we are not able to meet right now that you want us
to be focused on? What I'd like
to say as a reply to that question to
all council members is to appreciate
what the Houston Public Library is able to provide for our
citizens. But when you look at our
bottom line budget,
our bottom line budget, even with the increase this
year, is a far cry for even Chicago's Public
Library. That serves 4.6
million people with a budget of 100,000,003.
And our budget is at 50 million.
So you can see the difference.
So that would be it. The more money we have in our budget, the more
we can continue to provide services.
We staff our facilities at the bare minimum, except for
those that are the busiest. And I think
that's where the community is being shortchanged.
Because we had more robust staff,
we certainly could provide more services.
Thank you for that presentation and those answers. We'll now move into
the public comment period. The first public speaker
will be Mr. Jason Oliver.
Hi. I love the library.
I really appreciate everything that you all do.
I just want to start off saying that. Thank you. Thank you so much.
First. I know. The Harris County Library system has rolled
out the enhanced ID program this year. I actually
tried to use mine to come in. I don't know why we need
an ID to come into this building, but I tried to use it and wasn't
allowed. So I hope that that can change, because that's a really important program.
But I wanted to ask if HPL
is planning to join that and what will be needed for HPL
to be able to do that. So that's my first question.
And then second, it's often hard to find books by local
authors in the library's collections. How could we create a program
or initiative focused on acquiring the works of local
authors? So, first, that enhanced ID program, and then second,
local author acquisitions and wrapping those up?
Thank you for those questions. In terms
of enhanced ID, that's something that we can certainly
look into. We haven't had that as a priority for
the library system. We've had other priorities, but we certainly
can look into that and update you on that
research. And your second question was about
local author acquisitions and how we might be able to create,
just acquire more works by local authors.
We are increasingly
focused on building our local author collection.
We have an ongoing local author display.
We have local author programs inviting
local authors to come and even participate
in workshops when experienced
local authors will give advice to those
authors that are trying to start publishing
and how to get started. So we are focused
on it. We probably need to do more promotion
about that, but we are very embracing
of local authors. Okay.
I just find it hard to find their books in the libraries and especially
in the digital collections.
Author is not a part of the permanent
library collection. Right, and I can
explain more about that. I'd be happy to. Okay,
thank you. Stop up landing.
I just want a second appreciation
for the library. We love it. It's such a nourishing space
for the community and I love it so much. I brought my daughter and I'm
trying to talk her into speaking and asking you a question,
but for my time I have a question for you based on
your metrics. The library has a huge impact on Houstonians.
I know our family has felt that personally,
I'm curious what we know about whether library access or specific
services are equitably and how they're equitably
distributed across the city. Thank you for that
question. Our one Houston one library
master plan is based on that one word
equity. And we're looking many of the council
members have participated in seeing
that presentation of our master plan.
But it involves seven regions
and in those seven regions what we plan to do
is have similar services, if not the
exact services, similar services in each of those
regions so that people don't have to go from one
community to another unless they just want to.
But that's what we're striving to be a
city of equitable library services across the city.
I appreciate that and I love that idea. Thank you.
Geogrosal,
hi. First I want to say same thing about the
library. Actually, my number one thing I use most on
my phone is my Libby app. I love that app.
It gets the most use of everything that I use and I
appreciate it. And especially since the library has been closed, to be able to use
that has been phenomenal. So thank you. Thank you.
And I also tell everyone about it.
I wanted to ask you, are there any programs that the library I'm going to
invite you to do an ad for the library.
Somebody's going to come up to you and get that because we're looking to
have more user comments on
our library and if you found something that's really useful, I appreciate
that. I would love to do that for you. Tell me where and
when somebody approach you. Okay.
Are there any programs that the library is interested in implementing
or seeking to implement for which it doesn't currently have the necessary
funding?
How long a time do you have?
We always want to do more. We think we've hit
a good balance with understanding what the citizens
of our city want and need. We just like to do
more of it. Longer. That would require
longer hours, more weekend services, more access to
the library. Okay, well, let me know how I can help.
All right. Somebody approach you?
Roderick Butler. We're getting Sunday coming
soon. Didn't say that,
Director. I stand with
all of these people that we
would be wherever, do whatever,
because thank you. You are a treasure.
Libraries provide a safety net for communities,
for our children, for our adults,
and they are there in our good,
our bad, and sometimes they're just there, and that's all it requires.
But I would like to ask you about my community.
There is a little library called Scenic Wood Regional
Library. We would love this may be a CIP
issue to expand the footprint of that library.
Basically, the capacity. It has land to the north
of it vacant. It has land to the south of it. It's forest,
but it's still vacant. There are other libraries like Dixon
Library, which is new. We would love to expand the footprint of that.
I don't even know if Lakewood Library has come back online,
but we need to
know, do you have any plans for new libraries in the future
in your master plan? How do we get it? How do we support you,
and how do we give input for it?
We would love to have your input with
our planning for library
spaces and understand better what the
needs are. We have a good sense. We know that
there are communities that need more.
We do understand that. What I answered
about services is all about capacity.
It's about our CIP. It's about having
enough funding to go around. And I
meant what I said about equity. We're looking at each area of the
city and seeing how we can
be a more equitable department in
terms of providing services,
if not right away, a larger footprint, at least
the services in those areas.
Well, my heart is full and know that this is your army.
Yes, it is. So you just call upon us, all right?
Because we've all been in a library, and it
has benefited us. So please know that. Thank you so
much. Thank you.
Vice Mayor Pro TEM Cassex Taylor. Thank you. I want to
close with this comment. Director Lawson. When we were
looking to build our library in District A, we had an opportunity to
take a tour of some libraries throughout the city hosted
by your staff, and we've had quite a
few residents from District B to talk
about their concerns. But I will tell you, this is one
area where I can tell you firsthand that
District B is shining bright, because we got to
visit the library and saw the tech link and all the technology
in the library in District B. And I will tell you,
I was like, I want all that in our new
library in District K too. So I hear you
when you talk about equity and you talk about making sure that
our communities that have found themselves many times
to be maybe
not having the same level of resources that the library
has walked the walk. And the resources that are available in
the libraries in District B were phenomenal
when we were there on the tour. So thank you for caring about
the citizens of Houston and making sure that we
all have access to great quality libraries throughout
the city of Houston. We appreciate all that you do. This is probably the
happiest budget amendment I mean, budget session of
all of the ones that we'll hear over this week. So we
appreciate all the work that you do. Did you say amendment?
I have amendment on my mind because I'm thinking about those passports.
Thank you. I really appreciate all the support that all of
you give to the library.
Daughter Blending, did you want to sign up to speak?
I like the audiobooks that the libraries provide,
and I want more of those for
the libraries. We hear
you. Which library is your library?
Stonica Library. All right.
More audiobooks.
We'll try to accommodate your request.
Thank you.
Council member Cayman. Council member Cayman. Miss Blanding,
I just wanted to say you did a really good job. You're probably one of
the youngest people we've ever had speak at Budget, and you
were awesome.
And thank you for speaking up about audiobooks. We were debating
that, I think, a few council sessions ago about the
importance of audiobooks. So really, thank you for making such a
difference.
Thank you for your presentation. There are no additional in
person or virtual speakers before
we wrap up. Really say thank you not only to the director,
but your entire staff, the entire team, all of you,
all who work within the library department. We understand that
budgets are tight, and you all make the best of what you can
with the resources that you have. There are people all over
the city who truly value, and the contributions you
make to us are greatly appreciated. I think I heard you by saying there are
1.4 million cardholders.
Yes. That's incredible. We're rolling up
on 2 million. So that's incredible. So thank you all for everything that
you do. Before we adjourn, please note that the budget workshops will
continue to tomorrow, Tuesday, May 17,
at 10:00 A.m., with general services. Reminder to all council
members to be checking SharePoint for uploaded presentations as
well as responses for any questions submitted. Thank you again
to everyone for being here today, and this meeting is adjourned.
Thank you.